책임감 있는 컴퓨팅이란
quantum computing을 개발할 때
그 힘을 인식하며
잠재적 영향을 고려하는 걸 의미해요. 책임감 있다는 건
기술을 개발하고 사용할 때
미리 정해진 원칙에 따라 피해를 예방하고
잠재적 피해를 완화하면서
적극적으로 포용적이고
책임감 있는 솔루션을 IBM에서 발전시키는 거예요
저희는 수십 년간 사회에 대한 책임감을 갖고
일해왔어요. 오늘날 저희는 세상을 더 잘 돌아가게 하는 촉매제라고 자처하는데
그건 저희가 만들고 활용하는 기술의
함의를 고려할 책임이 있다는 뜻이에요
저희가 구축하고 활용하는 기술의 영향을 생각해야 해요
이 새로운 기술을 개발하면서
오늘 내리는 결정이 미래에 영향을 줄 거고
이런 결정들은
사회에 엄청난 영향을 미칠 가능성이 있어요
예를 들어 소수의 이해관계자에게만 도움이 되는 애플리케이션을 추구할지
아니면 소수의 이해관계자를 돕거나
사회적 문제를 해결할 수 있는 것을 선택할지 결정해야 할 수도 있어요
여러분이 고객으로서 quantum computing의
책임감 있는 개발에 대해 생각해볼 수 있기를 바라요
책임감 있게 생각하면 여러분의 비즈니스가 투자자와 소비자와의
신뢰를 구축하는 데 도움이 되고
직원들에게 성실함과 존경받는
명성을 쌓는 데도 도움이 돼요
고객들에게도요. 반대로
부정적인 언론 보도나 벌금,
제재로부터 보호하는 데도 도움이 돼요. 이 영상에서는
팀과 함께 논의해야 할 중요한 책임 관련 고려 사항들을
소개할 거예요
양자 컴퓨팅을 탐구하면서
그 응용 분야를 살펴볼 때 quantum computing에 관해서는
책임감 있게 생각하고 행동한다는 건
일련의 원칙과
가치를 따른다는 의미예요. 기술 개발을
안내하고 배포하는 데 말이죠
예를 들어, 이건 투명하게 공개하는 걸 의미해요
오늘날 quantum computing의 한계와 능력 모두에 대해서요
저희는 IBM quantum 클라이언트에게 요구하는
계약 언어를 갖추고 있어요
저희 시스템을 책임감 있게 사용하고
악의적이거나 불법적인 목적으로
사용하지 않도록요
저희는 이걸 책임 있는 사용
및 허용 가능한 사용 조항이라고 불러요
이 언어는 이미 고객들이 quantum 개발을 어떻게 생각하는지에
영향을 미치고 있어요
자신들의 사용 사례에 맞게요. 저희는
어떤 응용 프로그램을 추구할지 결정함으로써 quantum computing의 방향에
영향을 미칠 수도 있어요
개발과 가속화를 위해
잠재적인 무책임한 사용으로부터 보호하기 위해
저희는 강력한 IBM quantum
안전 기술도 개발했어요. quantum computing을 어떻게,
어떤 용도로 사용할지 생각할 때
quantum computing에 대한 기대와 타임라인에 대해
현실적으로 이야기하세요
quantum을 도입하길 바라는 시기에 대해
quantum computing을 신비로운 것으로
표현하지 말고 현실적으로 설명하려고 노력하세요
양자 물리학의 법칙을 따르는
컴퓨팅 하드웨어로요
quantum computing의 사용 사례가
적극적으로 포용적인지 확인하고
모든 잠재적 이해관계자를 고려하고 있는지 살펴보세요
어느 정도의 부정적인
사회적 영향이 있는지 파악하기 위해서요
사용 사례 탐구를 위한 명확한 원칙을
찾아야 해요
개발에 있어서요. 감사해요
시청해주셔서요. 여러분이
유용한 quantum computing을 세상에 가져올 때
어떻게 하면 책임감 있게 할 수 있을지도 생각해보시길 바랍니다.
The the